lakovic 19 à transformer le quotidien de
cette médecin en véritable course à
obstacles on est à pied d'oeuvre en
réponse à une recrudescence de besoin de
soins de fin de vie plus d'un et meurt
en réseau de lacs au vide et pas
seulement au csld dans les résidences
privées pour personnes âgées
c'est la catastrophe surtout pour des
grands malades qui sont en fin de vie de
covin 72 résidence pour personnes âgées
sont infectés par la coved et 50
ressources intermédiaires ont le même
problème le nombre augmente et certaines
résidences improvisent des solutions
dans une résidence de la région de
montréal des cloisons temporaires sont
érigés dans un espace commun pour ses
pairs et d'éventuels malades les
médecins raconte une réalité de plus en
plus brutale mais on voit bien dans les
résidences privées qu' il ya des
vieillards dans des chambres à n'en plus
finir qui grelotte de fiers qu'ils ne
mangent plus qu'ils ne boivent plus les
médecins tentent de limiter la
propagation et de sauver des vies mais
compte tenu de la dure réalité ils
doivent planifier des soins palliatifs
on va avoir beaucoup de décès à gérer
puis quand je disais ça gérer jeu qu'on
planifie bien les choses qu'on donne de
bons soins un jeu que les gens se
sentent accompagné c'est encore plus
difficile en ce moment étant donné qu'on
on peut moins compter sur la présence de
leur famille des familles qui offrait un
précieux coup de main on manque
définitivement de bras on manque de
ressources humaines pour faire des soins
fendi
dans ces milieux là ça c'est certain on
supplie le ministère qu'on ait des
équipes médicales séjour pour les
patients dans les milieux de vie du
domicile des ressources intermédiaires
et des résidences privées et le problème
est accentué au québec c'est qu'ici 19%
des aînés de 75 ans ou plus vivent en
résidence une proportion trois fois plus
élevé que dans le reste du canada
ici david gentilles radio canada
montréal